fossil fuel companies are suing
governments across the world for more
than 18 billion for taking action
against climate change that threaten
their profits according to research
conducted by campaign group global
justice now and provided exclusively to
sky news
tc energy rwe juniper rockhopper and
ascent are using a legal process that
allows commercial entities to sue
governments under international laws
governing trade agreements and treaties
the 18 billion they are collectively
suing for is almost a quarter of the
entire climate funding provided by
developed nations to developing ones
that's according to a recent assessment
by the oecd which put the figure at 78.9
billion dollars so what are these
lawsuits rockhopper is currently suing
the italian government for 325 million
dollars in a dispute related to a ban on
offshore oil drilling close to the
coastline ascent is asking for 118
million from slovenia after it passed
legislation requiring environmental
assessments for fracking
keystone xl pipeline company tc energy
is suing the u.s government for 15
billion dollars after it canceled the
project calling it inconsistent with the
administration's climate imperatives
meanwhile rwe and juniper are suing the
dutch government for 1.6 billion and 1
billion each following the dutch
government's move to phase out coal and
shut down coal-fired power plants
the majority of the cases are being
brought under the energy charter treaty
and are being hosted within the
international centre for the settlement
of investment disputes a branch of the
world bank sky news has contacted all
five companies who say their court
actions are simply to protect themselves
from the effects of the changing energy
investment landscape but climate change
campaigners say that energy companies
are responsible for harming the
environment and should be paying to fix
it rather than suing governments